all right so the holidays are now
officially over and now the paying for
it begins do we have to it's time to
just face those christmas shopping debts
john langler has some suggestions about
how to manage what you owe
you know it's coming your credit card
statement from december or whenever you
bought all those holiday gifts so how do
financial experts think you should get
those debts paid off for some shopping
during the holidays on a credit card is
all about those cash back rewards and
miles
but for others it's a way to still buy
gifts without spending your own money
right away i can see and understand why
maybe you know some are
maybe relying on credit cards a little
bit more now than than usual financial
advisors say it is never a good idea to
max out your credit card or come close
to your limit overspending can be a big
problem um you know first of all it can
hurt your credit score right these
credit rating agencies uh they want to
see you using a reasonable amount of
your credit limit however once you start
overspending you know that's a red flag
to them it also results in a cash flow
problem which could bury you deeper in
debt financial advisors say as long as
you have a plan you should be able to
manage we can control a budget right and
and and if you create a budget it create
it creates awareness on where you're
spending or where your hard-earned
dollars are going budgeting also
includes your credit financial advisors
suggest tackling your cards with higher
interest rates first but you'll also
have to make some small changes which
could pay off in the long run if you
spend eight dollars a day
for lunch monday through friday that's
about dollars a week which turns into a
little over two thousand dollars a year
now can you imagine if you had an extra
two thousand dollars in your pocket it
could be a huge difference
so little sacrifices here and there
you know can make a huge difference at
the end and there are other ways you can
plan ahead so you don't go into debt
next christmas you know instead of
waiting towards the end of the year to
start buying everything you know buy a
little bit throughout the year you know
keep an eye out for sales and you know
once once you purchase that just stick
it in the back of the closet until you
need it right luckily you have another
year to prepare for that next holiday
shopping spree just don't get in over
your head
john langler live local now